here we're today here for the uh Google
developer Summit session on gke and
unity a Matchmaker made in heaven
I'm ishan Sharma a senior product
manager in Google Cloud working in the
Google kubernetes engine
what excites me most about my work is
building a platform that powers some of
the most successful games in the world
gke as we call it is a managed
environment for deploying managing and
scaling containerized applications on
the Google Cloud platform
gke can be used to power a number of
critical player impacting game features
today in this talk
we will discuss how our partner Unity
uses gke to power its multiplayer
Matchmaker and how gke can be used to
scale these workloads to meet the
demands of millions of players worldwide
with that I will turn it over to guilla
hello everyone
um
next slide
that's me
engineering manager at Unity for the
matchmaking service
today I'm here to talk about like you
should just explaining about our
matchmaking service at Unity so a couple
items here we're going to talk about
Matchmaker and Unity gaming services
will deep dive a bit more into what is
matchmaking exactly
then talk about the architecture that we
have that we are using for for our
service and how we're using gke for this
and then we'll talk briefly about what
is next for the for the matchmaking
service agility
so let's get let's get going
so first of all multiplayer games are
extremely hard and extremely popular
sorry among all kind of Gamers casual
gamers core Gamers but also multiplayer
games
building multiplayer games is something
that's really hard developers need to
support a whole Suite of service that
when enables player to play their games
that's why with unity Services Unity
offers a whole Suite of multiplayer
Services which goal is to help creators
to make those games without having to
care about hosting or managing those
services
we can't wears we have James Lobby
netcode for game object relay Voice and
text type with Rebox as well as of
course matchmaking
and others that are coming that out like
very recently like friends for example
um so when we asked what are the most
important feature of our multiplayer
games to players here's what they are
saying they want to find a good match as
fast as fast as possible
they want to match with opponent and
teammates of their skill level and they
also want to match with their friends
all of those are matchmaking concerns
that's why matchmaking is a centerpiece
for a large number of multiplayer games
reserving them is not easy but you seem
as much Matchmaker and that's surfing
those problems for game developers
so let's talk matchmaking and get a
first understanding of where this
matchmaking precisely
so the primary goal of matchmaker is
through group players and parties
together in a match on a game server
Unity matchmaker is tightly integrated
with unity game server hosting so we
will mostly be talking about rigging
players together on a match that runs on
a dedicated game server
so where does a matchmaking flow looks
like
the first thing that the player would do
to join an online game is to create a
matchmaking ticket for their game
clients and send it to the Matchmaker
then the Matchmaker takes all the ticket
that exists and try to group them as
well as possible together
and this is done following the
matchmaking configuration that has been
defined by the game developer we will
talk about that in details later in the
presentation
once the match is made Matchmaker will
request game server hosting to allocate
a game server for that match Matchmaker
will provide information such as what is
the build configuration that game server
hosting is supposed to run for that
match what does the match that was made
looks like GM and player composition so
then when the server starts it has
information about who are the players
who are supposed to join and the
distribution between the teams
once the server is allocated cam server
hosting provide information about the IP
and Port players are supposed to connect
to the information makes it back to the
ticket that was created by the players
and as the player pulls for the ticket
status once the information about the
game server allocation is added to the
ticket player will know about to connect
once they added information they can all
connect directly to the game server that
was allocated for them and they're
playing their game on a dedicated game
server
so
that looks pretty simple at first grant
right
saving a matchmaking ticket grouping
playing grouping player together sending
a request to allocate a server
save the information about the server
and return the information back to the
to the players
but the reality is quite different let's
go we're gonna go through where we think
it's so complicated to create a
Matchmaker service
so
the most important thing is to select
properly segment your pre-appropriation
the number of player that we try to
match together has a direct and Python
and time to match appropriation to low
and attempt to match increases it takes
because it takes time to find player to
match
a population too high on the contrary it
takes time to go through all the player
that wants to play
for it for an effective matchmaking we
want to only try to put together players
that can potentially be matched together
that's pre-appropriation segmentation
population can be supplemented in
different ways like those examples we
have here
cues like game modes version of the
games or player characteristics
so how to make sure that the match that
is created makes sense and that we are
matching the right players together
first we need to be able to define the
composition of the match how many
players are in one match how many teams
how many players in a teams is it a
value 1v1 match is it a 6G players
better wire made of 30 teams of two
players
can the game start even if the if the
game is the match is not full
and we also need to provide a way for
game developers to Define more intricate
rules like making sure everyone has an
equivalent skill level making sure that
everyone in the gym is using a different
character for example
but also we need to provide a way for
those rules to become more and more
lenient over time it can be better to
have a match that is not well balanced
than not having a match alarm
so operating on live service that is a
critical part of the musical multiplayer
experience is hard if a game rely on
matchmaking to allow players to play
this needs to be running like 24 7. we
also need to keep in mind that games can
have different life cycles games that
are in development highly anticipated
anticipated games with high CCU at
launch times vivore games with that have
like a low traffic at launch and sudden
spikes in traffic and even daily
variations in current concurrent users
that have like resource requirement
different depending on the time of the
day
so the question is when is the right
time to invest into making a matchmaking
service is it even worth it how to
figure what are the right resources
together for those different scenarios
so now that we have exposed some of the
primary take around how complicated it
is to build a Matchmaker let's take a
look at how Unity aims at solving those
issues
so first we're going to see how we're
providing tools for game developers so
that they can dynamically segment their
population and adapt to
population variations
then we're going to review how can
developers can customize their
matchmaking configurations to tailor it
to their needs
and then how we allow Google players
together based on their connection
quality that's quality of service
integration and then how do we handle
sustain a high throughput of tickets as
well as spikes in ticket influx
so
unity's Matchmaker allows for different
way to segment player populations
first of all cues the support game
driven segmentation of preparation like
game mode 1v1 quick match ranked
Etc player from different queues will
never be matched together
then we have for hqs excuse our
divided into pools pools are a dynamic
segmentation of prayer populations that
is using attributes that are defined on
the matchmaking ticket
they are low to segment players based on
the game version their rank or if they
are cheaters for example
pools are much blurrier segmentation as
we're going to see players from
different pools could potentially end up
being matched together as the opposite
of queues
gonna show some example of our UI this
is the unity dashboard here we're seeing
the the Matchmaker that's configured
with two different cues the quick match
that we were talking about and the
ranked and we can select the quick match
as four pulls configured
then let's look at
the pool configuration of the queue here
we can see that poorer configure in the
context where a game developers would
like to support multiple incompatible
version
of a game as well as a cheater item each
pools has a set of a set of filters that
are different figured out in which Polo
ticket should end up
pools also have an order that has an
impact on the whole player are being
distributed in the different pools
foreign
so
here are four different pools that
support a better version of the game the
official version of the game and for
each version version a cheater item
to determine in which pool a ticket is
supposed to end up Matchmaker will look
at the attribute of the ticket and then
look at the first pull of the queue and
check if the attributes fill the filters
if it if it if not it moves to the next
pool
the last pull
don't have any filters to ensure that
tickets that don't match any attributes
eventually fails into into a pool anyway
so
now this is the final set of the ticket
distribution in the pool based on the
different attribute and filters we can
see player C in the one in one One beta
cheater player B in the no cheater and
then AMG in the 1-0 no cheaters as well
so
now What's Happening Here is that we're
Rising the game developer realizing that
they probably don't have enough players
in the pool of this beta version and
attempt to match is actually already
high and the player experience is not so
great
is that the game Driver parties have
decided to disable the to disable sorry
the cheetah Island for the beta version
of the game
the result is that the centricate will
be distributed differently player b and
c will now end up in the sample bringing
two smaller population together
increasing the chance to find a match
so what about the configuration of Apple
with custom matchmaking we're engine
we are a game developers to define the
composition of the match what is the
right number of Team what is the right
number of players
it also allows for more advanced
matchmaking rule like we were talking
about earlier like everyone has a
different character in a gym
this ranging also supports recession
about time of those rules Arrow
intervages time to match when the player
population is lower
this is an example of a configuration
for a match requiring 20 teams of three
players to start a match it's pretty
simple and straightforward configuration
it's just very easy to understand if
you're used to read Json
as an example of something a bit more
complex that uses the example I was I
was taking earlier
the mesh is made of certificates
HTM members must have chosen a different
character and everyone in the match must
have chosen to play on the same map
but the thing is that this is a quite
restrictive configuration right and we
may not be able to find anti-players to
start the game fast enough
so we're going to allow to relax the
minimum number of chimps to start a game
to 20 teams after 15 second allowing for
a match to start even though if it is
not full
alright so if you don't like to play
with Json files we have a pretty nice UI
that's just like a quick example that
allows game developer to modify the
matchmaking rules without having to use
just another
next
creative service how do we allow to
match player together into the same
region Matchmaker integral support
creator of service that is integrated
with game server hosting this server for
game developers to enforce that players
who are matched together have an
equivalent credential connection quality
because different games have different
needs it is possible to configure rules
based on latency packet loss percentage
or even both
but the player preparation can be lower
on a specific version of the world so we
may want to be able to eventually to mix
pay appropriation together so like any
rules of course with Quest rules
can relax over time by just time to
match
here's an example of what this looks
like if a game developer will want to
enforce all the players in a match
to have a difference of latency of 30.
eventually relaxing over time after 15
seconds to our defense of latency for
100.
scalable infrastructure
how to make sure that we have the right
resources to handle the fluctuation of
traffic first of all matchmaking service
is backed by
Google kubernetes engine from the Google
Cloud platform this technology allows
almost an image it's carried up in the
cloud to support extremely high traffic
then there is Veterinary no cost for
pools that don't that don't receive any
tickets so we do not create resources
for those pools
finally the Matchmaker architecture is
built to support specs in traffic while
the service gets up
so now let's dig in the the architecture
that allows for the stability that we're
looking within the team Matchmaker
how are we supporting queues and pools
and the cat energy they could create
game developers can have today 10 cues
in each environment and each queues can
have 10 pools that's a potential of 100
in total in each environment
with two-do approach of evapori is not
receiving any tickets we will not spend
any resources for that pool that's what
we call scale to zero there is virtually
no cost for a pool that does not as
receive any matchmaking ticket
that enables us to rationalize our costs
requested allowing for wide
customization on the Matchmaker
so before we move on I want to introduce
some Concepts that we're going to talk
about the next few slides we're going to
talk about what is a ticket bucket a
ticket bucket is
a combination of a project ID and the
environment is targeting development
production staging
the name of the queue and the name of
the pool a ticket will always belong to
a bucket
then match process
a bucket need a process to run in order
for its ticket to be matched with each
other
there is a one-to-one mapping between a
bucket and a process
and the process can only match tickets
of a given bucket
a process will also need to
we also need the matchmaking
configuration defined by the game
developers to understand how to put
players together
and finally a mesh process hosts a match
processors is basically a kubernetes
part that executes one or save our match
processes as we're going to see
so
scale to zero
initial State let's start with the
initial State initial State sorry
no processes are running no match
processors are scheduled Matchmaker will
schedule required resources to process
matchmaking tickets on demand as we just
talked about
our map
right here
will keep track of those resources in
order to know if a pool of ticket
already has a process running
so first
a ticket comes in created by your player
will determine that this ticket will
fall in the bucket one
Matchmaker array from the world map that
a ticket for the bucket when has arrived
no processes are running for that bucket
and also no match host exists either so
the world map will create a match
process host record and assign the
process for the new bucket to that host
when the match process hosts record is
created on the world map Matchmaker
takes care of scheduling a new batch
process for its deployment
and when the host starts it creates the
warm up about the processes that is
supposed to run and then fetch the
matchmaking configuration for that
process
the configuration contains between other
things the matchmaking rules
once the match process is ready to match
tickets all the ticket for bracket 1 are
forwarded to the host that is running
the bucket wine process
Next Step
two shows up from a ticket for bucket
no process is running for that bucket
either but there is a host available
with some
available process space
so the world map will just go ahead and
add that process on the already existing
host
warm up in from the host that it is now
supposed to run a new process for
bucket2 the match process host feather
configuration again for that bucket and
start executing the matchmaking process
and then just as before Auto ticket for
Package 2 are not forwarded to the to
the host
after some time
we end up in a situation where multiple
hosts are running with multiple
processes and the world map is used to
know how to ride the ticket to the right
destination
now back advantages with safety case for
radar wire
that means that we can save Resources by
by removing it warm up will remove the
process from the host and from the host
they should stop running it effectively
allowing for a new process to be
scheduled on that host
if after some time a host doesn't have
any process running the horse itself
will be removed
so here's a high level of a view of our
architecture we are purposely remove
some companies that are more generic to
keep the most important part of the
matchmaking service
first of all the ticket I received from
the game client on the front end that
saves them on our tkdb
those tickets are sent into a queue that
we allow them to prepare to process them
asynchronously
the front-end also send ticket signal to
the control plane the control plane is a
service that will look into the world
map to determine
if a process is already running
or if we need to schedule a new process
then when the process is scheduled the
mattress is informed like we just talked
about earlier
five ticket watching worker act as a
buffer between our front-end and our
match process and then make sure that
tickets are making it to the right
destination
they use the warm up to understand when
to sell the ticket
once tickets are matched together
that matches
the match is created assigned to the
batch workers but we've got a match
workers that are responsible for
requesting server allocation and putting
for the status of the server allocation
and once the server is allocated
matchmakers and tickets
with the server information
so how are we leveraging Google Cloud
platform and Google kubernetes engine to
build the service and the architecture I
just described
here is a high level architecture of our
gke deployment
matchmaker is a kubernetes native
service it uses kubernetes API to
schedule a match process host
it is made of six deadliest deployment
for them on the critical path that can
scale horizontally based on traffic
to stateful set for Ticket database and
our warm up
we also use website for asynchronous
workout like writing tickets requests of
server allocation and just make sure
that message is always delivered and
also act as a buffer when the service is
asking up
we're also using different managed
database like memory store and firestore
for configuration and this kind of
things
and finally we use data flow which that
is sending to basically they're
basically is saying to a website topic
and transform messages into metrics that
are forwarded to
our internal data pipeline that will
then display them
on the Matchmaker unit dashboard
so
the nice thing about kubernetes
application and gcp is that everything
can be managed for code
our infrastructure resources are created
through terraform
services are created through hem shots
and that makes deploying a new
Matchmaker on gcp for development
purposes very fast and reliable
this enabled for a much faster
development iteration
allows us for a reliable and easy
deployment of Matchmaker in our
different development environment and
staging environment and this simplify
the different integration tests and
helps us making sure that the
integration of the different Services we
have are working as expected
displaying confidence and the changes we
are pushing weekly to production and
we're also able to run very large
testing early in development validating
the architecture of the Matchmaker
some of the gke key benefits that for
you
that we are using today
the G key High availability and
reliability allows us to build a service
with a very high overall uptime
the number of gke node and the speed the
scale out are thus allows us to quickly
react to specs of traffic as well as
giving us the ability to sustain highest
throughput
and finally the tooling like the managed
properties and Cloud logging enables to
track issues very easily
so
sorry spider out
um gke allowed us to scare out hundreds
of nodes allocating thousands of CPUs
and hundreds of gigabytes of RAM for a
full-scale testing that allowed us to
vary that the architecture of the unity
Matchmaker
so here are some deliveries that we got
keep in mind that those are lab tests
with a steady influx of ticket that will
always find a ticket to match with which
is not the real life
that's a total of
153 million concurrent users who are
playing a 20 minute games that's more
than the steam platform today
with more bucket
this number could also be increased but
we figured it was not necessary we ended
up the test here we are quite happy
3.3 second time to match for the 95
percentile
and 1.5 seconds for the 50 for the 50
50th percentile sorry
what's next
what's next for Matchmaker
um
so coming soon we have our matchmakers
and configures files to match configure
much more much more easily a Matchmaker
if you don't like the UI if you want to
include your configurs code in your in
part of your cicg pipeline this is
coming
we have
a decoupling Matchmaker from game server
hosting to all those matchmaking into a
Lobby and using the unity relay
a Matchmaker IB testing allows you to do
experimentation on your matchmaking
rules on your hosting these kind of
things Matchmaker archetype space
templates
as well as later this year Matchmaker
into like third party housing support
peer-to-peer and dedicated game server
and much wizard analytics and Reporting
that's it thank you so much
[Applause]
yeah let's keep it going thank you so
much this was such an amazing talk isn't
it amazing to see how it's always
humbling to see how our customers and
partners use the capabilities of the
Google kubernetes engine platform to
accomplish such amazing things so once
again a big round of applause thank you
so much for sharing with us
I think we have a couple minutes for
questions uh some microphone back there
um
anyone wants to come up ask any
questions this is your chance
yes I can have small question
I'm interested in how you flexible your
filtering system
the deal is the game can be completely
from chemical operative
yeah I'm sure I understood very worthy
question
do you hear me
I have yeah go ahead okay so I want to
make the game so I don't know I I like
Led Zeppelin and beer and I want to find
somebody to play with me so the game is
cooperative not competitive
how flexible your rule system
yeah filtering so basically like
multiplayer which is our game server
hosting system is super like any any
kind of
servers right so you can run like unity
game server it's gonna work like Google
go servers everyone like any kind of any
kind of servers that you want any kind
of executable you want to run on a on a
server basically so can I connect your
filtering system to my database into my
rules
sorry can I connect your
filter system to my database and through
my rule base
choose total external server
so if your question is to
hosts using matchmaking to use your own
server that's something that's
eventually that's gonna come up later
this year no I have very tricky rules to
combine the people together
so and
I don't I want to use my my C my system
to create the rules and filters for this
okay I understand sorry yeah so sorry so
we don't uh we don't support custom
rules today
um
and that's not something that we have
read on the roadmap right now so we will
have to use like our custom rules engine
to do like this kind of this kind of
things okay I'll be very curious to hear
what kind of just because you have so we
can we can see uh maybe we can already
do it with our custom engine
thank you
any more questions
foreign
you mentioned that it was kubernetes
native but uh is that support for your
GK autopilot or just regular
no no so that's uh that's kubernetes
achieving the sense that we are using
kubernetes apis to run the Matchmaker so
we create on demand we create resources
we create kubernetes resources on demand
it's not something that you can take and
put into your own uh into your own
so the infrastructure is all under the
hood we as a client of Unity gaming
Services we have no access to the
infrastructure no exactly yeah you would
have to use our SDK and our apis to be
able to
create matchmaking tickets and get their
matchmaking results Yes actually
one more question
in one of the first slide you add the
rally coming soon do you have an
approximately date for this or a quarter
or something like this
I think we're saying let me go back
quick we are saying uh Q2
okay cool thanks
question to maybe both of you so going
forward because costs are important
especially if you go scale
um do you have any idea I know this is
really hard to answer because it might
depend on some internal decisions but
cost wise going forward do you think
there's going to be any optimization in
either the way you set up the way you
run things or so on or building or how
how is pricing going to change maybe
going forward if
so on our side what we're looking at is
like we're looking at optimizing our
workload and especially the the match
process workload so we're trying to look
at okay what kind of CPU do we need for
a much processors to be running and how
much how much RAM do we need to do that
and we're looking at different sizes
depending on this on the how complex the
matchmaking logic process is depending
on the rules and depending on the time
it takes to iterates over
a bucket of tickets
and that's something that's something
that we're looking to optimize to
optimize the costs of our Matchmaker
mostly okay so you're you're still
because the question was more like
you're still looking into this right
it's still going to get better you're
still going to try to improve this right
yes cool thanks
anyone else
I think it should be it that should be a
wrap thank you so much
[Applause]